[Music]
hi everyone its Johanna here is the
festive season and I absolutely love
this time of the year Thanksgiving is
coming up Christmas and New Year is next
month and how can we go by the festive
season without having or indulging in
desserts
we can't that's why I've made some
really easy quick and delicious plus
healthy desserts just for you
all these desserts can be made for a
party and there is no baking required
see I listen and have made them really
pretty as well just so they suit the
festive season let's see what we have we
all love cheesecake and even if you
don't like cheese you will like this
mini berry cheesecake because there is
absolutely no cheese it's packed full of
healthy ingredients it's really good and
I have to be careful not to eat too many
of them and because it's mini it's
perfect for your party or for a
gathering there are three layers to this
cheesecake so let's start by
constructing the crust the ingredients
you'll need are 1 cup of pitted dates
you can choose module or halawi dates
and quarter cup of peanut butter I
prefer to use 100% peanut butter because
they are basically peanuts that are
already processed for you alternatively
you can choose to use half a cup of
whole peanuts or cashew nuts almonds
peanuts any nuts or you can even mix
them up what you need to do is to soak
your pitted dates overnight and for this
recipe we will need a food processor so
the first step is to add your dates into
the food person
and just process it and now at your
quarter cup of peanut butter or have a
cup of nuts and continue to process it
what you'll have is a nice and smooth
texture and this is a cross for your
cheesecake and to make your mini
cheesecake what I have here is a
silicone muffin tray it's really good
because it's non sticky and it's
flexible therefore it makes it easy to
get your mini cheesecake out so we want
to only be using 3/4 of this mixture and
place them evenly into the muffin tray
so that's what you have it won't be
perfect but that's fine so place this in
the freezer and allow it to set with the
remaining ingredients take one teaspoon
of cocoa powder and just mix it up and
I'll press it down into a really small
block what I want you to do now is to
cover this up and place this in the
freezer and let it set as well and we
will be using this for the second recipe
as we are waiting for the crust is set
in the freezer let's move on to making
the cheesecake
the ingredients you need are 1 cup of
whole cashew nuts soaked overnight and
drained 2 tablespoons of melted coconut
oil 2 tablespoons of lemon juice which
equals to 1 small lemon or half of a
large lemon 2 tablespoons of honey and
half a teaspoon of pure vanilla extract
melt the pure coconut oil using a double
boiler again we will be needing our food
processor what you'll need to do is to
pre-soak your cashew nuts overnight or
at least up to four hours the first step
is to grind the cashew nuts
and now just add your lemon juice
coconut oil 2 tbsp of honey you have a
teaspoon of vanilla extract and just
blend it again what you'll have is a
white creamy texture and this is your
cheesecake remove the muffin tray from
your freezer and top it up with your
cheesecake what we want to do now is to
place this back into the freezer and
you'll find a layer the mixed berries
sauce it's so fruity and the sweetness
will seep into the cheesecake the
ingredients you'll need are 2/3 cup of
frozen berries thawed and mashed which
is about 100 gram and 1 teaspoon of
honey mix the honey and berries in a pan
under low heat for one to two minutes we
do not want to be cooking it so Allah
you mix berries to cool down once it's
cool add it to the final layer of a
cheesecake and place it back into the
freezer and finally place this in the
freezer for four to six hours or
overnight all we need to do now is to
remove the cheesecakes from the silicone
muffin tray which should be easy
this mini buried cheesecake is perfect
for the festive season in fact all year
round each one of them has 306 point six
calories it's packed full of good
calories from your nuts coconut milk and
honey so indulge in them in moderation
we all know a dessert menu is never
complete without having chocolate in it
so what I have here a chocolate fudge
mousse to die for they are absolutely
delicious they make you feel so guilty
but so satisfied at the same time I have
previously shown you how to make a
healthy chocolate mousse dessert with
this recipe we want to add a little bit
more texture by adding some chocolate
fudge so let's start by making the
chocolate mousse the ingredients you'll
need are 1 block of silken tofu which is
about 300 gram one block of dark
chocolate about 100 gram and just 2 tbsp
of milk so the first step is to break
your chocolate bar into pieces and melt
using a double boiler you can choose to
use a food processor but I prefer my
smoothie blender add the silken tofu and
dark chocolate into the blender and
blend it up if you find that your
mixture is too thick you can just add a
splash of milk not too much and blend it
again and this is what you'll have a
thick chocolaty mix pour the mixture
into 5 small dessert glasses what I have
here are small recycable wine glasses so
let's place these desserts in the fridge
for 4 to 6 hours or overnight for them
to sat in the Sun of the video I've
asked you to store
quarter of your cheese crust away and
we've added a little bit of cocoa powder
onto it so remove that from the freezer
what we want to do now is to slice them
up into really small nuts and that will
be your chocolate fudge just take the
chocolate fudge and top it up onto your
chocolate mousse dessert the recipe is
for 5 surveys each serving has one
hundred and sixty eight point seven
calories at a small ribbon and they are
perfect for the season Cheers
and finally I have to share with you my
comfort food which is a Malaysia
favorite dessert called pooper cha-cha
Boober means porridge cha-cha I am not
too sure what that means
Boober ChaCha is like rice pudding in
the western country but is made of
healthy ingredients such as pumpkins
sweet potatoes ginger and coconut milk
so the ingredients you will need to make
Boober ChaCha
are 300 gram of sweet potato sliced into
small cubes 300 gram of fresh pumpkin
sliced into small cubes as well 70 gram
of tapioca pearls of sago 35 gram of
Chinese brown sugar bar 200 ml of
coconut milk which is about half a can
about 400 ml of water and 1 small slice
of ginger root crushed the first step is
to boil the pumpkin and sweet potato in
a large pot for 20 to 30 minutes until
tender
in the mean time so the tapioca pearls
in water for 10 to 15 minutes and
drained
once that's cooked just drain the water
off and just live enough water for the
brown sugar to dissolve add your brown
sugar and your crushed ginger in and
just stir it and allow your brown sugar
to dissolve reduce the heat at your
tapioca pearls or sago and stir well and
finally and your half a can of coconut
milk for the rich creamy texture and now
just stir it and allow it to simmer for
10 minutes
and the low heat what you just made are
five servings of uber ChaCha and each
serving only has 100 94.3 calories and
do you serve it in your favorite bowl we
can serve it hot or cold but I prefer it
hard especially
because the weather is getting so cold
right now I understand there are a lot
of negative remarks in regards to sugar
this brown sugar bars are actually made
from unrefined cane sugar and according
to Chinese medical experts this brown
sugar bus provides wonders throughout
the woman's body improve blood
circulation and relief pain
it's especially beneficial to women who
has just given birth or have an
irregular menstrual cycle you can buy
them in any Asian stores they are high
in calories therefore we have to consume
them in moderation I like that in my
dessert because it makes me feel really
good especially when the weather is so
cool outside and it's good to your tummy
with coconut milk it's very rich in
vitamins and minerals it's a great dairy
substitute it's very commonly used in
Asia but they are very high in calories
again we have to consume all these
healthy food in moderation so do try my
booger ChaCha out and let me know
whether you like it or not
remember healthy food does not mean low
in calories so enjoy them in moderation
as part of your balanced diet make them
for your family make them for your
friends let me know what you think in
the comments below and just enjoy this
beautiful time of the year for new
fitness food and motivational videos
please like share and subscribe to my
You Tube channel and website do you
follow me on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter to stay connected with me thanks
guys
[Music]